my guest this week is the author of
guerilla mindset a lawyer a tweeter and
a free speech activist Mike Serena
welcome to the show thanks today for
having me on it's it's good to have you
here we've done this in 140 characters I
say that to a lot of my guests but the
whole nature of our relationship is 140
characters and you can be able to expand
on 140 I have a podcast too I can run my
mouth so wealthy who out talks each
other alright there you go so let's
start off just so for the people that
don't know you tell me a little bit
about your history where you come from
and and what got you to write the book
and then we'll dive into that okay cool
so I grew up small-town kid flyover
state which everybody hates now because
we're all redneck backwoods you know
hateful bigoted people sigh I ever say
it was that Illinois okay so I grew up
in the middle annoy nothing but
cornfields and soybean farms and I
realized that I don't really like this I
want to do something more with my life
growing up I was also kind of a fat kid
got bullied a lot I got picked on then I
got into martial arts and you know
started sort of beating up the people
who bullied me and created that little
conflict cycle got that out of myself as
the bully dream right yeah that's the I
guess that's the bullied kid dream is
that you get bullied for a while right
well I see some martial arts you kick
some ass well I got I got back at
everybody but one guy but he went to
prison for it actually so I was actually
home when I was 22 when I saw this guy
went into the bathroom and I was gonna
go and just slam his head in my friend
goes what is wrong with you manicure
this happened when you were like 13
years 22 now you know I was like yeah
okay yeah got that out of my system
yeah it's funny because a lot of people
do seem to repeat the things that happen
to them without were 13 like if you were
bullied people they then become the
bullies right dolt right and that's
probably why I hate bullies so much now
just you realize these people are trying
to ruin lives and it's as bad as bad
vibe when you're a kid now I don't
really like calling adults being bullied
okay you're an adult you should know how
to or you being online bullied okay you
should learn how to kind of chill out a
little bit right but I I don't like a
lot of the online bullying stuff that
goes on in terms of Oh
tweeted something wrong let's ruin this
guy's life let's get him fired from in
many ways let's get a guy fired over a
tweet is probably worse than throwing a
Kindle locker-room because that guy has
a family this is livelihood or what
happened with say justine sacco mm-hm
you know you can't find a job and like
whoa maybe that is even a little bit
worse yeah what happens wait so that's a
little bit of a sidebar but just that
her case you want to just lay that out
cuz it was really I mean nobody really
knew who this woman was she put out one
tweet you can yea justine sacco is the
best example of the outraged caller
culture she was a nobody 120 followers
all of her friends and she tweeted
heading to Africa hope I don't get AIDS
oh wait I can't I'm white lol right got
a joke yeah just stupid
yeah she was a hipster she's actually
trying to be ironic mm-hmm and she gets
on a plane for Africa back then you'd
have Wi-Fi on the plane to Africa a
she's in the air and I shouldn't laugh
it's actually a tragic story they
started a hashtag has justine landed yet
yeah everybody now hates justine sacco
she's evil nobody said hey you know what
you mean by this you know what's going
on and to be clear nobody really knew
who this person was so this was just the
perfect example of the internet going
crazy yeah she was a nobody she wasn't a
public figure she didn't work intact
what happened probably one of her
co-workers saw it and wanted to do a
little backstabbing it was somebody made
personal drama international news
everybody went after her and it touches
on so many themes where well I mean
that's a woman she was getting raped
threats are the people the the social
justice warriors the activists if you're
leading a sort of hate mob on a woman
who gets raped threats well wait isn't
that what you say I do but I've never
done that right we don't ever do that
okay so let's hold off on some of the
social justice stuff first but and by
the way I want to go on the record I did
not jump on that Twitter bandwagon cuz I
remember thinking this is crazy this is
just some person who said some stupid
thing so I can't be outraged by somebody
I never heard of right until I saw this
little tweet but a little bit back to
your history and then woke up yeah so
then I was deciding on where to go law
school I looked at a map I read the the
data the data says you're gonna live
within 50 miles of where I go to law
school statistically speaking and I go
well if I go to law school and Illinois
that means
life will be a little ship on Illinois
so now I moved to California kind of too
big of a okay language too afraid to go
live in LA to go to UCLA to go
live in LA I'm a small-town kid I'm
driving on the 10 for the first time
like oh you know out of people how
do people drive in this traffic but I
figured I could go to Pepperdine it's in
Malibu and then I could kind of visit LA
as I wanted to so mal bless a very
small-town vibe best of both worlds yeah
and you're right on the beach it's
pretty pretty sweet operation over there
at Pepperdine yeah but I mean you know
how it is wherever you are you don't
appreciate what you have right first
couple days it's magical
majestic yeah after that you just look
into law books anyone right okay so you
so you became a lawyer right but then
really will put you into the public
space was you wrote your book the
gorilla mindset yeah and it's very much
I'll let you explain it but the my main
takeaway is sort of that you control
your destiny
is sort of the the takeaway that I got
but what what made you write it and what
is that do you think that's a fair
assessment yeah it's you create you
define within certain confines your own
reality you know your dave rubin i'm
externa your life is your life my
life it's my life but we're gonna have
different experiences in terms of how
you live on a day to day basis but we
got the same drama we're pissed off at
people we don't feel like we got
recognition we wonder if we're gonna
lose their jobs how money to make money
doing this what if I you know ask that
girl or guy out on a date what if they
think I'm dumb I'm afraid to go on TV
because people think I look stupid I
sound funny what if I say the wrong
thing we all got the same problems
mm-hmm you know how am I gonna pay my
bills so ultimately you want to control
your thoughts you want to control your
emotions learn how to to not lose it
essentially and the reason I wrote is
because I went through a lot of drama
had a lot of you know you grew up you
grew up poor now you're in the big city
you got to figure it out you have um you
see this in a lot of writing actually
where people tend to be ashamed of their
upbringing so instead of saying hey I
grew up a poor kid in a small town but
hey here here I am now you want to say
yeah I hate rednecks and because you
want to get away from that right so you
kind of over react well why is that well
because your mindset it's the way you're
framing your back
around so what we tend to do is we think
well I grew up this poor dumb kid what
will ever do with my life but you can
just say what I mean I grew up a poor
dumb kid I'm here I made it somehow I've
learned and I've grown and I start to
take these background experiences and
create a new future out of those yeah
it's interesting the way we sort of
fetishize being the recipient of
bullying or being the recipient of sort
of anything bad so I think for me I was
bullied as much as I bullied other kids
you know like I really I had some kids
that I probably bullet I don't like the
word either just it's so played out it
doesn't mean anything
but I probably treated some kids pretty
shitty and give the kids that were
higher on the social thing in high
school
treated me pretty shitty and Here I am
so so big will big deal but we have this
idea somehow that if you're always on
the recipient end of it that somehow
you're better and that's a really
bizarre thing and I guess that goes to
the heart of your book you have to be
the one to say well I'm not gonna be
bullied anymore right yeah well we
ultimately define our realities based on
other people and there's a lot of
reasons for that we should and and I
teach you don't do that so for example
shame we've all been ashamed
oh my god I'm embarrassed well why Oh
some complete stranger thinks you're an
idiot right right well why are you
letting that other person define your
own reality which is what what you do
when you let people shame you attack you
sort of bully you you're now saying well
I'm gonna let other people control how I
feel and then you start to think well
why would I let other people control how
I feel how does this make any sense of
my life
and then you start to reframe that that
kind of stuff into a stronger mindset
yeah so that concept is very much in
line with the online culture and I know
you're a big part is because I see you I
see you fighting with people on behind
you're calling people out people are
attacking you I mean you're really in it
in the in the sort of like back and
forth piece of it so I guess the way you
deal with that is that you just don't
take any of it too personally right you
can't take it personally and you always
have to you always got to take a
negative reef a minute reframe it as a
positive it sounds cliche but you could
say oh my god I have all these people
saying mean things about me or you could
just say wow this is great how do these
idiots that I've never heard of
here about me well I must be doing
something right I must be making impact
so you can let criticism define you
Madonna said this once actually she goes
if I go into a room and there are
hundred people and ninety-nine people
like me and one person doesn't that one
person who doesn't like me that's what
sticks with and we tend to be hardwired
as human beings to let criticism bother
us which makes sense because if we're
living in a small tribe 150 people there
if five guys don't like you you know
they might take you out on the hunting
trip and kill you right right but we're
not in that environment more we're in a
big global environment I've even written
about you know you just have to niche if
if 99% the world hates me
1% like me dude I would be filthy rich
right now that would be great you know I
would I would love to have 99% of the
world hate me right I mean that's always
reminds me the thing from Howard Stern's
book and in the movie when they're
talking about the the executives are
like you know the people that like you
watch you for four minutes right and the
people that hate you watch listen to you
for three hours or something well my
haters will dredge up posts that I wrote
maybe when I was in a bad mood or
whatever no I don't even remember this
like how do you guys find this stuff for
though those like confront me with
things I don't like wow you guys are
great you're you're pulling up these
archives so that I don't even remember
[Music]